- Buyer power, the bargaining
power of buyers of products
or services of the firms
operating in the industry.
Here the issue is to
focus on how easy it is
for buyers to drive down
prices and capture more margin
for themselves.
Buyers will differ by industry.
If it's B to B then the
buyer is another business
in the industry value
chain, perhaps a supermarket
or a department store.
If it is B to C, then the
buyer is the final customer.
The power of buyers is driven
by the number of buyers,
the importance of the buyer
to the firms in the industry,
the ease or difficulty
of customers to switch
between firms in the industry, and so on.
If you have only a few
customers then they are often
able to dictate terms.
Buyers are powerful when
buyers are concentrated.
That is, there are only a few buyers with
significant market share.
For example, if you sell
into the defense industry
you're dealing with only one customer.
When buyers buy significant
portion of your output.
For example, Walmart
demands low prices from most
of its suppliers.
Most Walmart suppliers sell
a significant proportion
of their capacity to Walmart.
When buyers could just as easily produce
the products themselves.
For example, auto manufacturers
could credibly produce
a lot of parts that they
source from their suppliers.
Buyers are weak when
buyers cannot easily switch
between firms.
For example, once I buy
a car I am locked into
the parts and services
provided for that car.
When firms in the industry can threaten
to forward integrate and
sell directly to customers.
For example, movie companies
could own movie theaters
or release their movies
directly to customers
by their own streaming platforms.
When firms in the industry
supply critical components
to customers.
For example Intel semi-conductor chips.
Firms designing them
into their products have
no other option.